[Music]
are you encouraged to fight with your
co-stars ah yeah that's like the whole
point of reality TV they definitely put
you in situations where there's likely
to be drama they'll put you in a smaller
group setting to allow that to happen
naturally off-camera and we let the
producers know and then they wanted us
to repeat that fight on camera which
only like increase the intensity of it
because neither I most wanted to do it
we're definitely not encouraged if I
drinking to the mix not knowing each
other having no cell phones no TV we're
gonna get on each other's nerves a
little bit the other person on the show
with me was told to start some things
with me because they felt like I was
gonna you know bring it which I did but
it was still me to you or other people
on your show turn up personalities for
the camera yes they do WI as fun as they
say otherwise I think everybody knows
where and when the cameras are on
including myself I'm guilty you can't be
like hi my name is John who the heck
would want to watch that you've always
got to turn up you don't turn up you're
not getting near time you're gonna be
edited out the show or barely be in the
show our personalities are real we
didn't turn it up for the cameras we got
casted because of our crazy ridiculous
personalities and it's just us you get
paid to be on a reality show
yeah we do get a slight bang I'm not
gonna go and travel the world with the
sight of myself it wasn't much this
season to go on you typically get paid
more because you can negotiate your
contracts well we got paid for episode
everyone makes about 10 grand grows from
like $2,500 I think per episode and it's
kind of like Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire so I should get closer to
first it's like take 150 thousand
dollars fifty thousand or second third
and it kind of goes down do you feel
like you have to do your hair me
perfectly every day because you're
always on camera I did feel like I
always had to do my makeup and I always
had to have my hair done which is quite
expensive I mean you want to look the
best that you can on camera I actually
tried doing and I have to coach myself
through it
I had my female roommates helping me was
a little bit nice because I had to do it
myself
come on make up but hear ya got a big
room nice you got workout always got
look fresh if you're not fresh don't
even be on TV I would try to keep up
every day with the old man bun and the
hair you kind of look good on camera we
only get one outfit for the time being
that were out there so hopefully you're
wearing something that you enjoy wearing
because it is a long 39 days do I ever
watch my show yeah I mean I watched it
at the time it's hard to watch me on
camera normally I don't like to watch
myself on TV of course I watch my show
and not only do i watch my show I have
episode release parties with my friends
for my show
come on like I'm not gonna be there for
two months or a month whatever maybe and
not watch my show I watched it when it
was airing and then I laughed we did but
after that I mean I'm not like reliving
my glory days and watching it every
night before I go to sleep I did watch
it and quite frankly I don't need to
watch it again
once I know your voice sounds really
annoying all the time
absolutely i watch my show nothing else
beats survivor
nothing do you ever get used to a camera
following you ever
I would say after about a week or so you
kind of forget that they're always
around first quoting got used to it or
within the first like couple of days and
like oh my god I woke up I looked at
Carissa next to me my cast mate and I
was like ah there's a camera in my face
at the beginning it wasn't seen I was
like subconscious oh my god when I
wasn't dating naked oh that was weird
cuz I'm naked and have someone like
right there on you like hey I'm looking
at your uh mega parts
no no but actually in the end the guy
kind of got used to it a little bit so I
go ahead and start acting my personality
ten times higher I had never been in
front of a camera before like that I've
never been on TV before
not into acting none of that kind of
stuff so but after you know three or
four times and a few drinks things get a
little easier does the publicity ever
affect you- yes oh my god people would
use you hey you know comes for TV yes I
do have hookups but guess what
you're not getting them don't just ask
me to hang out me for that people are
always gonna have your their opinions
about you regardless so you just have to
be grounded within yourself and not let
people's words get to you I thought that
I was just going to cry when I flew
during Twitter and social media I read
these comments that people write to me
at times and you can't help but laugh
and just brush it on your the rug what
is the best perk about being reality TV
star getting free stuff and getting paid
to go places obviously all the dick pics
that I've been getting haha I am a
social worker first and I get to talk
about what I do and what I love social
services and with foster children I get
to tell the masses about it I'm able to
give back to my community in trying to
promote you know some healthy healing
and anything to do to help it was fun
it's been an amazing experience thus far
someone change it for the world
[Music]